Recently, there are many foreigners who come to Japan and live stream or
make videos in order to gain popularity.For
these creators, I
have created a list of things to do in Japan.Japanese traditional
Participating in the game Battle Royale, aiming to become the first foreigner to win, live-
streaming from Sakurajima's caldera,
trying jumping off the stage of whatup GU Shimizu,
watching the rumored cursed videotape with friends, watching it with everyone.  Hey, I'm going to sneak into Godzilla's sky. I'll
introduce you to a nice woman, so
please live stream your date with her. Her name is, um, Asami Yamazaki. I'm going to film inside the U.S. military base in Yokosuka. I think you can enter even without permission.
Try it out and
play a game to see who can avoid the Shinkansen first.Staying
in the dog village.Going for a drive for a change of pace.Catching a
blowfish while the clowns are running and eating it as is.That's right, it's
not that fresh.  and anyoneEL
Get
buyI
want to prank a ninja.If I have free time, I want to hang out in Ikebukuro's West Exit Park.In
February, I want to climb Mt.Fuji.I do
n't need any climbing equipment.If the number of views is important, I'll probably
stay on the 4th floor of my accommodation in Japan.  Well, 4 is a lucky
number, so try picking a fight with Hanzo. It'll
definitely be an interesting live stream. No, Shibuya and
Harajuku are fine, but they're packed with people. By the way,
if you want to play a prank,
go to Gunkan Island.  What to do is to arm wrestle with Mr. Shizunai,
okay, I'll prepare it for you, so I'll
eat a big pickled plum in one bite.Then,
Japanese people will be interested in
YouTuber boxing.There's a
little YouTuber in Japan called Mamoru Takamura.  I'm
looking for a match partner right now, so I'm going to
challenge him, and I'm going to grab the sleeping Tengu flower, and I'm going to
steal the cloth from Kirika, and I'm going to
tell Ma-san my name, and I'm sorry, but I'm
playing Japan so much.
If you want to make a lot of money, try the traditional Japanese culture of Hakiri in your own country
JA